para transferir energía a un objeto
tenemos que ejercer una fuerza en ese
objeto a la cantidad de energía
transferida por una fuerza se le llama
el trabajo realizado por esa fuerza la
fórmula para encontrar el trabajo
realizado por una fuerza particular en
un objeto es doble
igual a efe por de coseno de teta w se
refiere al trabajo realizado por la
fuerza f en otras palabras doble uno
dice la cantidad de energía que la
fuerza
efe le da al objeto f se refiere al
tamaño de la fuerza particular que
realiza el trabajo
de es el desplazamiento del objeto que
tanto se movió mientras la fuerza estaba
siendo ejercida y la teta enelco seno de
teta se refiere al ángulo entre la
fuerza que realiza el trabajo y el
desplazamiento del objeto y se pueden
preguntar qué es lo que está haciendo
este coseno de teta aquí este coseno de
teta se encuentra en la fórmula porque
el único componente de la fuerza que
realiza trabajo es el componente
horizontal aquel que tiene la misma
dirección que el movimiento del objeto
el componente de la fuerza que es
perpendicular a la dirección del
movimiento no realiza trabajo alguno
notamos algunas cosas en esta fórmula
las unidades de trabajo son newton por
metro a lo que llamamos jules los bulls
son las mismas unidades con las que
medimos energía lo que tiene sentido ya
que el trabajo es la cantidad de jules
de energía dado a un objeto o sistema
pueden ser la cantidad de energía dado o
al objeto o sistema si el valor del
trabajo realizado resulta positivo para
una fuerza en particular significa que
esta fuerza le está tratando de dar
energía al objeto el trabajo realizado
por una fuerza va a ser positivo si esa
fuerza o componente de esa fuerza apunta
en la misma dirección que el
desplazamiento y si el valor del trabajo
realizado resulta ser negativo quiere
decir que esa fuerza está tratando de
quitarle energía al objeto el trabajo
realizado por una fuerza va a ser
negativo si esa fuerza o componente de
la fuerza apunta en la dirección
contraria a la del desplazamiento y si
una fuerza apunta en una dirección que
es perpendicular al desplazamiento del
objeto el trabajo realizado por esa
fuerza va a ser cero lo que significa
que no está dando ni quitando energía
otra forma en la que el trabajo
realizado por una fuerza sea cero es
cuando el objeto no se mueve ya que el
desplazamiento sería cero
así que el trabajo realizado de sostener
unas pesas muy pesadas no realiza ningún
trabajo en dichas pesas ya que esas
pesas no se están moviendo así que esta
fórmula representa la definición del
trabajo realizado por una fuerza en un
objeto pero qué sucede si queremos
conocer el trabajo neto o el trabajo
total realizado en un objeto podríamos
encontrar las cantidades individuales de
trabajo realizado por cada fuerza en
particular y sumarlas todas pero hay un
atajo para encontrar este trabajo neto
para mantener las cosas simples vamos a
suponer que todas las fuerzas tienen la
misma dirección que el desplazamiento
del objeto de esta manera nos podemos
librar del término de coseno de teta y
ya que estamos hablando del trabajo neto
realizado en un objeto voy a reemplazar
efe con la fuerza neta en ese objeto
nosotros sabemos que la fuerza neta
siempre va a ser igual a la masa por la
aceleración así que podemos reemplazar
efe
m ahora así que encontramos que el
trabajo neto es igual a la masa por la
aceleración por el desplazamiento y
quiero escribir esta ecuación en
términos de las velocidades y no en
términos de la aceleración por el
desplazamiento así que les pido que
recuerden una fórmula de la cinemática
la velocidad final al cuadrado es igual
a la velocidad inicial al cuadrado más
dos veces la aceleración por el
desplazamiento para usar esta fórmula
cinemática tenemos que suponer que la
aceleración es constante lo que
significa que suponemos que la fuerza
neta en este objeto es constante y aún
cuando parezca que estamos haciendo
demasiadas suposiciones deshaciéndonos
del coseno de theta y suponiendo que la
fuerza es constante ninguna de éstas son
necesarias para derivar la ecuación que
vamos a obtener solamente hacen más
sencilla esta deducción así que viendo
esta fórmula cinemática nos damos cuenta
de que también tiene la aceleración por
el desplazamiento así que despejó la
aceleración por él
desplazamiento y las pongo en un lado de
la ecuación y me queda que a por d es
igual a la velocidad final al cuadrado
menos la velocidad inicial al cuadrado
entre 2 y ya que esto es igual a a por d
puedo reemplazar a mi aporte en la
fórmula del trabajo por lo que el
trabajo neto realizado va a ser igual a
la masa por la cantidad de final al
cuadrado menos b inicial al cuadrado
entre dos si multiplico los términos en
esta expresión me queda que el trabajo
neto es igual a un medio por la masa por
la velocidad final al cuadrado menos un
medio por la masa por la velocidad
inicial al cuadrado en otras palabras el
trabajo neto o el trabajo total es igual
a la diferencia entre los valores
iniciales y finales de un medio de m por
b al cuadrado y esta cantidad un medio
por m por b al cuadrado es lo que
llamamos la energía cinética del objeto
por lo que muchas veces escucharán que
el trabajo
realizado en un objeto es igual al
cambio en la energía cinética de ese
objeto y esa expresión se conoce como el
principio de energía trabajo ya que
relaciona el trabajo neto realizado en
un objeto con la energía cinética ganada
o perdida por ese objeto si el trabajo
neto es positivo la energía cinética va
a aumentar y el objeto va a aumentar su
rapidez si el trabajo neto realizado en
un objeto es negativo la energía
cinética de ese objeto va a disminuir lo
que significa que va a ir más lento y si
el trabajo neto realizado en un objeto
es cero significa que la energía
cinética en ese objeto se va a mantener
igual lo que significa que el objeto va
a mantener una rapidez constante